well hello and welcome everyone i'm
debbie douglas for those of you that
don't know i'm the curator of science
and technology and the director of
collections at the mit museum
and gathered with me on this lovely day
in october 2021
uh are the museums for directors
uh distinguished members of our advisory
board and my many hard-working and
talented colleagues on the staff today's
session is being videotaped for
posterity so we'd be grateful if you
would silence your phones and
be relatively quiet
although we'll welcome all
uh
bouquets and cheers
that you might be inclined to share with
our
distinguished speakers today is the
final
program to be held in the mit museum
facility at 265 massachusetts avenue
i want to begin with mit's land use
acknowledgement statement
mit acknowledges indigenous peoples as
the traditional stewards of this land
and the enduring relationship that
exists between them and their
traditional territories
the land on which we sit is the
traditional unseated territory of the
wampanoag nation
and we acknowledge the painful history
of genocide and forced occupation of
their territory and we honor and respect
the many diverse indigenous peoples
connected to this land
on which we gather from time immemorial
it is good for us to remember that our
50-year relationship on this site is
only the most recent and that the
history of this place is much older
so we have here four people some of you
know them all some of you know one or
two of them
warren siemens warren is the founding
director of the mit museum but his
tenure at mit is
predates that he was in the air force
even
earlier
um
the museum of course uh his tenure with
this what we call the mit museum began
in 1971 and continued to his retirement
in 1996.
he was
passionate about history arts culture
and mit and
he has entrepreneurial instincts that
quickly apprehended something that mit
in 1971 had not fully known about itself
and that secretly
mit loves history
in 1994 warren had appointed mary lean
as associate director it was a new post
i believe at the time
the museum was growing and it needed to
focus its operations finances and
staffing
to professionalize them and over nearly
three decades mary has built the
operational infrastructure that has
enabled the flourishing of every single
person program exhibition fundraising
effort expansion and more that has been
dreamed up since her arrival
but twice mary has also served as acting
director between 1996 and 1998
uh and then again between 2002 and 2005.
and jane pickering was appointed in 1998
and served a four eventful and
transformative years
in
the history of this museum before
departing for yale's peabody museum she
subsequently returned to cambridge in
2013
as the inaugural director of the harvard
museums of science and culture and more
recently in her new position
as the william and muriel seabury
howells director of harvard's peabody
museum of archaeology and ethnology
alan brody once
who was
philip corey's predecessor the associate
provost for the arts once described john
your arrival in 2005
not so much as an appointment
but that rather you had been shot out of
a cannon into the institute's midst
mit has
had come to recognize and value the
achievements of warren jane and mary all
the more exceptional considering the
limited finances facility and staffing
that they had but could it scale that
was the question and the challenge for
john who came to us as one of the
world's leading scholars on the public
engagement of science and from
leadership positions at prestigious
posts throughout the uk
the question was
could he increase the visibility and
impact of the museum by two or three
orders of magnitude but warren i wanted
to
ask about begin by asking about the
museum's early years
and i want to pause for a moment and set
the stage for
all of us here tonight
and bring you back to 1971 when gas was
36 cents a gallon
when walt disney world in florida had
opened for the first time when nasa was
launching its final apollo missions when
the arpanet debuted when ali fought
frazier when the temptation sang just my
imagination
cigarette advertising on tv had just
been banned the voting age was lowered
to 18 and americans were painfully
divided over virtually every issue of
consequence from race and gender gay
rights the environment housing education
jobs and most of all the conflict in
southeast asia
so given all that upheaval and discord
of that moment 50 years ago
uh when plans are being made for the
october 7th 1971 inauguration of jerome
wiesner
the theme of that inauguration of a
10-day event was called introspection
wiesner sensed that the moment that
called for reflection
was at this moment was called called for
reflection and rededication of the
community to the values and ideas we all
share there was a 10-day celebration
they'd never done anything like this
before that featured concerts and
colloquia and parties and exhibitions
but today i want to call attention to
one particular exhibition it's called
retrospect mit
19 or excuse me 1861-1916
now the tech reports that the exhibit
was organized by professor richard
douglas the
head of the department of humanities so
warren i want to have you start off this
conversation by saying how did you get
involved and how did this small exhibit
of photographs and drawings from mit's
first 55 years of history turn into an
accredited museum
very simply i
i
i was
in the department of humanities as the
administrative officer
and the head of the department richard m
douglas
sent me a note
which is probably here in the file
asking me to find a few photographs to
put up
for an exhibit for jerry wiese's
inauguration
so that sounds simple i'll just go to
archives and
pick up
choose a few photographs and
put them up
well i went with photographs it was very
quickly informed that they didn't
collect photographs
that they only collected the official
records of the institute and photographs
were not part of that
so i started searching and we started
finding things everywhere we turned
around
i need to say sort of the beginning that
my previous job at mit prior to the
department of humanities
was in the personnel or human resources
that we now caught
and in that position i
was in charge of
finding hiring
uh promoting whatever you do to the
hourly people and there are a lot of
hourly people at mit
so i got to know not only a lot of the
hourly people but their supervisors as
well
and they uh
for example one of the our major finds
in
getting going
was i called on my friend
elmer condon who was head of the movers
and i asked him if he knew where
he knew where everything was everybody
just gave elmer the
stuff they wanted to get
rid of and he would find a place usually
in in this building by the way
and the first thing he led me to was
the
uh a room up on
fifth fourth floor i guess
that had not only william barton rogers
portrait
the original one that no one had seen
for a long long time
but about 20 other
important
portraits and busts
and
i immediately took the
portrait of william orton rogers
down to howard johnson
and
he immediately told
james ryan killian
the saint of all saints as far as i'm
concerned
and uh
killian asked to come up and need to
bring him up here to see it and he said
don't let any of this go we got to save
the history of the place so that's the
basically the beginning so we started
gathering
and physically searching for whatever we
could find and we filled an entire
building with it again
so the museum i mean excuse me that
exhibit went up in october but
presumably it came down it was in the
corridor in building 14.
uh what happened next we started what
became historical collections
and
that
with that i re started i reported
directly to howard johnson for the first
two or three years i was the only person
with institute who reported directly to
him
and uh
that that led to
a a true search
going through every storeroom in in the
at the institute
and this in turn led to a lot of
interest in with the alumni
uh
we had all sorts of things that
the alumni were more interested in
most mit alumni would rather talk about
their history
than they would about the latest
scientific
advance
and uh that's true so we we started
drawing
a lot of
interest from
alumni
and in
our fifth year which would be fifth year
of existence probably 76
i invited the members of the class
uh at the reunion to come up and see us
we were still back in
in a small part of the other part of the
building
and that's part of that
they were so impressed that
by what
they had seen we although we didn't
really have official exhibits
that they both both the class of 25 and
35
made
suggested that mit collections
historical elections be given part of
their class gift
well this is a no-no
and that got us the interest of of
the higher-ups and
we just had to fight from there
i think john and jane particularly
and mary of course is the mastermind of
keeping track of all this it would come
as a bit of a shock that warren was
forbidden
from raising money
i thought it was compulsory
on that front
warren in
the early years you had a really intense
service mentality of
doing exhibits for anyone and everyone
who asked
from the corridors at mit to
i read in the president's report that
you even took very early on a trip to
the
florida to the kennedy space center and
represented
mit and
and what
you know in the historical collections
to a couple hundred thousand people who
visited
tell us a little bit about how you
cultivated that service ethos and and
some of the early team members who
worked with you
uh
as far as the audience well
uh
if i get the question correctly uh
i started uh at the request of the
alumni association to go to tour
um
mic clubs around the country and i think
i hit
every club in florida at least three
times and there's a lot of clubs in
florida i hit uh everywhere from saint
paul minneapolis minneapolis-st paul
to montana
to
uh
actually some in new england so
word spread through that
that group that we existed and that
helped
as well so i was
invited to do a lot of things that
helped spread the word and
i should indicate that there was a
tremendous i by this time
um
oh i should say at the beginning that we
had no budget none whatsoever
and uh our main workforce was
northeastern work study students
and we owe northeastern a tremendous
amount because we didn't pay them
anything
and we continued to have work study
students through
even after we could finally start to
hire mit students but then we were able
to hire
some staff
since barbara linden who was came from
the archives was a mainstay
we had michael
yates who had been a work study student
who became a regular staff member
we had we built up a very very
good and talented staff
of people who were really dedicated and
could see a future in
in what we were doing
so
one of your pivotal acquisitions came in
93 when you bought the holography
collection and that's about the
from the
museum of holography and that's about
the time mary you and jane came on board
and i wondered if we might
ask you some questions about the
mid-1990s mary maybe you can reflect on
those
you know first years and
really here's the burning question is it
true that mit wanted to get rid of the
museum or thought about getting rid of
the museum in the mid 90s
well i remember joel moses who was the
provost to challenge us about what is
the purpose of the museum and does it
serve
mit students
so we we had to document that i mean we
we did then we do now
we're a resource for students and
faculty and classes and
providing materials original materials
for their work
and i think we also made the case for
how the museum serves the public but yes
debbie we were challenged by the provost
so jane you come in tell us what were
your first impressions of this play i
mean you come from
[Music]
england
[Laughter]
i mean
so yeah i was thinking about that
because
that was a question that was asked when
i was interviewed like
why should mit have a museum and i
remember thinking
that in some ways i mean you always get
that question in a university museum
right you're always being asked about
service to the university
you know like versus service to the
wider community and hopefully the two
actually are the same thing
um
but i remember thinking that the mit
museum was almost like the purest form
of a university museum because it really
was a museum of mit
and and so many i mean where i'm working
now we're sort of a museum of the
university but not really because we
have a
sort of real disciplinary focus right
we're i'm in an archaeology museum right
now
uh and whereas mit felt like the museum
could be mit's museum and i came in and
it felt
sort of
multi-disciplinary before that was sort
of fashionable now everyone does that
but it sort of was before that that you
know we had the historical collections
the holography collections and i
remember i'm sure
people here i remember don stidson
um dear
um person that we miss
and don taking me round the galleries
and seeing these holograms and he was
you know you know how everyone thinks
they know what a hologram is and they
really don't they think it's something
on a ruler you know um
and him very patiently explaining to me
what actually a hologram was and so then
i'm in the holograms and then suddenly
i'm in this exhibit gallery with arthur
ganson's amazing sculptures and it just
it almost felt liberating that like wow
this is a museum that could really be so
many things and so many things all at
the same time
but also a sense of okay we do sort of
need some sort of focused mission
that thinks about mit and particularly
the sort of art science issue you know
just things that
that the mit museum could be really
really good at um and so yeah i think
there was definitely that sort of
but that's that's often a pressure but
yeah there was definitely a feeling of
that i think
so john we you know know that you had a
wife here in cambridge but you were a
thriving professional in the uk and
what is it that
kind of sucked you over here beyond uh
the desire to maintain good family
relations yeah i was actually spending
too much on air miles or whatever it is
in the period before
i came here so there was that but
i think that
it's rather similar i think to what uh
jane's just been saying there's
something about the potential i still
think today actually the potential of
the place is far greater than the actual
and that's exciting that's something to
go for you know i mean it's not very
inspiring to be in a place where you
think well it's pretty much done
everything it can
and um it's just a matter of cruising
for who wants to be in such a place i
don't know but not me so i i was very
attracted to that um it is a feature of
museums in general i think
that they are
in a certain sense ambiguous as to what
their true character is if i mean i'll
make an analogy with academic
departments if you ask well what exactly
is the department of aeronautics and
astronautics i mean you don't need to
ask because it's kind of obvious
right but if you ask what exactly is
uh the gardner museum or what exactly is
the mit museum it seems as if the
question needs to be answered and it's
not i'm not original in pointing out
that it's a great advantage of museums
that they have this ambiguity because
they can be molded and shaped
and they can do all sorts of things and
and
i i think exploring the envelope of what
you could do
and what might be interesting and what
might be productive is part of what
makes it a joy to work in a place like
this it feels very mit i mean yes
i've worked in many different
universities so
it feels you know sometimes i'm in a
situation where i think
ah yeah i remember that happened at yale
you know and you're you're trying not to
sound all super like oh i worked in all
these great universities but
but
mit is different i mean i can safely say
that having worked in several
universities
but it felt like a place where you could
do all that and actually it was
encouraged and was sort of typical of
the rest of
the community one thing i will just
comment i'm interested to know if this
was true also for every all of my other
colleagues on the table on the bench
here or wherever we're on
um the panel
i mean
mit likes to know what's going on and
there is a whole administrative
structure no one has ever questioned
me
about
why we're exhibiting this or why we
chose that topic why are you doing this
thing called the enemy which you know it
was all about international conflict
um or intra-national conflict actually
as well and there was a great liberty
and there is a great liberty to explore
to experiment
was that always true i mean warren was
that true for you did you feel under
pressure to exhibit certain things or
were people happy for you to do more or
less whatever you and your colleagues
decided
uh
if i understand we just
we could do anything we wanted as far
exhibits
because we had no
we had wonderful collections and there
were building collections
so
we took
after we
developed exhibit space on in here we
also took over compton gallery yes in
the main campus so we had a really good
exhibit space there and then we took
over the heart nautical
collections and gallery and so
we just
we just had as wide a variety as
possible from
charles woodbury
who is the
american artist to
an early american impressionist which
has
happened institute house
he graduated in 1888 i believe
and uh so we could do whatever we wanted
to no one no one told us anything right
and we did have an advisory committee
which was very supportive and yeah it
was early days and helped us open doors
and
find materials and so forth so
you raised a question you
shared woodbury i know is one of your
loves but i'm curious with the others if
you have
particular objects or collections or
programs or projects that you've had a
particular passion for
during your
tenure here
well i'll share
i'm very interested in architecture and
design so i love the architecture and
design collection which comes out of the
bozar tradition
we have incredible drawings and plans
and we had the opportunity when the
architectural
collaborative
firm was um disbanding to acquire some
of their archive and i'm afraid that i
was helping with the dumpster diving and
rescuing some of those plans um but they
as it turns out they are now one of if
i'm not mistaken one of the most
requested collections because there are
many
buildings designed by the firm tac um as
it's known that are being restored or
are being worked on and so you know the
that documentary evidence um is really
important
um so that's
that's one of my favorite
collections so that's totally brilliant
mary um because i sort of liked all the
others
not that i have anything against
architecture
but
i sort of was like oh wow the history
you know the hacks the holograms there's
a lot of h's in that um you know and
then the heart oh my god that's four h's
okay the heart nautical collection so
for me it was just so sort of exciting
to see all these different things many
of which i knew zero about i remember
coming in and saying to people
i'm like
she says modestly the best director to
have because i know absolutely nothing
about any of these things so i could let
you get on all these amazing curatorial
and collection stuff you guys can get on
and and tell me what you need and let's
think of a vision and let's you know but
i i'm not i don't know one end of a
yacht from another you know i i learned
quite a lot about the history of science
and mit culture
you know pretty quickly
um
but yeah so so i it's hard for me to
pick for each of us yeah yeah yeah so
it's not that i want to say i don't like
architecture gary
say that but
since mary said that i thought i could
say i have a different sort of answer
because i love lots of the stuff but the
thing i really remember being so pleased
about when i first came
was that this museum actively collects
because i had the previous experience in
a very large prestigious museum which i
will not name
since i'm now going to criticize it yeah
which had such a large collection of
such a sense of self-importance that it
had largely stopped collecting
and i
struggled there to try and persuade
people that you know science and
technology which was what this place did
hadn't stopped
and they ought to be collecting modern
stuff and when i came here as i think we
probably all have done
i'm guessing with warren i'm afraid
there was a collections committee and i
duly attended and every single meeting
there are new acquisitions
and gary and debbie and the rest of the
curators are coming forward and saying
look at this thing and we have we just
collect sometimes we collect things and
you think well i suppose so
but more
more often it's like wow you know i
remember the day it was um probably more
than 10 years ago now debbie will know
when we had the opportunity to collect a
whole series of 1950s and 60s
toys
children's toys that were
made by claude shannon
one of the founders of information
science and technology and he made these
things to amuse his kids because he
thought it was boring i think to go buy
a store a store toy when you could
design something better and they were
better i mean they're amazing juggling
machines and
one of the world's first chess playing
machines
we have these things in the collection
it's amazing um um some of them will
even go into the new museum you know
that's the thrill for me of being here
that the collections keep doing this
which we have to have a talk with
associate provost curry and the provost
occasionally about because it means that
you know we keep running out of space
but that's another story well and the
great thing about the collections
committee and i'm sure this was warren's
doing was having claude brenner as the
chair of that while i was there and
he was someone that i dearly loved and
was so kind to me especially at the
beginning when i was like
i don't know anything about mit and he
sort of would talk with me and he had so
many stories and he and i'm assuming
that you knew him well warren and yeah
that was
he was a yeah a great person and he ran
the collections committee really really
well you know
i
am curious you've shared about your love
of collections but i have a lot of
exhibitions and programs colleagues here
i'm wondering uh
if you might give some
share some of your
most
enjoyable innovations i'm thinking of
fat and fast and soapbox and of course
we can't the science festival and i
i'm just wondering if uh you might share
some
stories about some of your
uh favorite or memorable or challenging
programs
and or exhibitions that
you undertook
during your tenure here
well
to me it's amazing how uh
how quickly the
we got support but i wanted to point out
one example
uh
the al hill was a vice president of
research i think
and he asked us we were coming to the he
had been come to to mit as part of the
rad lab
and he wanted to do something to
celebrate while there are still a lot of
people around to celebrate the
the
history of rad lab so he asked us if we
would go down to uh
outside of harrisburg pennsylvania
to
choose a few photographs from
the collection which had been taken
directly from mit and put into federal
storage there
so we get down there
and
uh
found very quickly
that it was a huge
collection that it was also due to be
just
destroyed it was in the channel to be
destroyed within the next six months
so i called elle hill and
he called right back and said
rid a truck and bring the whole thing
back so we got the whole history of
photographic history of the rad lab it's
just in one fell swoop and it that
to me is exceedingly important part of
mit story the rad lab and how it
transferred
transformed mit into a
top flight not that it wasn't top flight
before the top flight research
university as well as
other things but i could go through so
many of the
collections that came in the same way
came in as a bulk
like the hologram collection for example
we bought we were
sent to
an auction to pick up a few pieces that
steve wanted to have
here at mit
and we ended up getting the entire
collection of
holograms
because they wanted to hold the
collection together
yeah how many holograms was that oh i
don't know we had more than two thousand
more than two thousand largest
collection in the world right it's by
far
just like that we just happened to get
the whole thing you know
warren mentioned though reunions and i
have to say that the reunion event
around like the rad lab the whirlwind
computer people we did it with lasers
we've done at
lincoln laboratory number of occasions
the museum has hosted
really significant events with pioneers
in
computing and radar and and the like and
i'd have to say warren you really
innovated the reunion event you know
which often had an accompanying
exhibition
a program um gatherings with people as
one of the first most successful types
of programs this museum had
but opportunity for collecting oral
histories which you know are so
important for documenting
whatever the activity is
but i know jane you and john
really also began to
push outward and bring some new kinds of
programs for families and other
audiences and i wonder if you might tell
some stories about those so i was
thinking about that because you had
mentioned that last week and of course
the friday after thanksgiving science
was brilliant i have to say nothing to
do with me but just really really great
staff that come up with an idea and
you're like that's the idea
um and now i can't remember what fast
stands for other than science and
technology family adventures in science
and technology yes and i remember we
started that
and that was really great but you know
thanks to arthur and then the other
thing i really
enjoyed and i remember because it was
just as you were starting debbie
um was the exhibition on artificial
intelligence it was called was it called
robots
yeah yeah i think so so anyway we did
that because
um i remember we were
slightly short-staffed um as often was
the case uh and so i ended up and this
was pretty debbie
i ended up doing a lot about the history
of ai which i knew nothing about
but working with rob brooks and other
members of his lab and everything which
was
really fun
and then spending ages getting this um
actually non-mit
electronic robot from bristol england
which was on loan to the smithsonian oh
no no it was at the smithsonian and we
got this loan um and rob brooks just
being he said to me there's this thing
and i've always wanted to have it and i
think the turtle yes yes yes yes the
turtle yeah yeah so managing and being
so impressed by the power of the
internet because i was able to track
this down and at the time you know it
wasn't quite like today but anyway so so
i loved that doing that exhibit um
and it felt like because the other
exhibits had sort of come in under your
tenure and mary's with the holograms and
arthur ganson sculptures but that was
something that that we did that was sort
of sort of new
um and then fat and fast of course felt
just as a credit to
what you're saying jane i mean we didn't
finally manage
to stop
um the friday after thanksgiving chain
reaction until just a couple of years
ago i mean we the reason was that arthur
ganson
whose idea it probably had been it was
him and one of our staff was there
marsha and
thirst and lighting marsha and cassie
and uh
sort of collectively came up with that
by the time i got here arthur was the
impresario who was overseeing this
extraordinary chain reaction
and he also made the final
link in the chain so he was kind of
essential
and each year we'd say well would you
mind doing it next year oh all right
then you know and then i might make next
year my last year and then you get to
well perhaps one more
and this went on and on and on you know
and uh it went on because it was you're
absolutely right it was just right for
the mit museum and we would have
in the last stages of the program we'd
have you know the best part of a
thousand people
on bleacher seats yeah
looking at all these teams making uh
extended chain reactions in the
gymnasium i mean just
and i hope that that tradition will
carry on in new ways i must say
in the new museum my choice of
exhibition is very difficult but since
you asked i mean of course i have a
special fondness for the cambridge
science festival not least because i
always suspect
that putting up the
genome trail which must rank as one of
the most difficult exhibits i ever
oversaw
along
the street between kendall and
harvard square for the first year of the
festival i think it went right outside
phil sharp's office and he saw this
curious structure on the street and
that's how we came to get the link with
phil which
has been very important to us so i have
a double reason for liking the festival
but when it comes to exhibitions i i
think i've just got to shout for this
thing we did recently called the enemy
which happened in this space and it was
an entirely virtual reality exhibition
it was a great achievement by our
exhibition team pulled it off it was
also a collaboration with the center for
art science and technology and the hula
is here
it was very very hard to do
and very very memorable for anybody who
actually went into the exhibition was
like you've never done anything like
this before
and to me it was a special thing
i did want to point out one
factor that
played a critical role in building the
collections and
getting word out
we had
our first two students that we mit
students that we hired in the museum
we had no money to pay them of course
but that didn't stop us
so we uh
we uh one was scott ferguson class of 78
and he uh organized a trip a tour
of every
store room on campus
literally every store room and we worked
with the department
administrative officer who i knew from
my
time in humanities
and we found
phenomenal stuff
and just that we fill in the basement of
it here with that
the other one uh of those first two
students was david
uh
sure
i
forgot huh dave carp
david carp yes of course
uh david
had a special knack for vic uh
repair uh
working with phil and we had taken over
a staggering amount of mit
film that had come from various
departments and so forth
and one of the things he did was to uh
do a film of just as an example he did a
film
uh he
we had in the collection but had never
been
restored or shown
a film taken in the early 30s at the
mining at the engineering camp in
downeast maine
machias
and that
film
was shown to
the class of 35
and one of the
of the
leaders of the class
was watching it and big tears were
rolling down his eyes because he
couldn't believe
that the film from 1931 of him being in
east machias even existed
and this i mean that shows you how
important and uh
that's
i guess that's why i'm an honorary
member of class of 35.
that's that's another matter entirely
but i have to tell a secret story though
that scott shared with us a couple of
years ago when he visited on this tour
this was when mit
everything was keyed and it's the
pre-schlage system all yale locks and
there was actually a campus master key
and
warren you had made arrangements for
to get hold of one of these keys to
facilitate this
inspection of all these closets all over
the place so that they didn't have to
pester department chairman and the like
to get into these places
scott revealed to me later as warren you
gave them this key and you made them
swear six ways to sunday that you they
weren't going to lose it they weren't
going to give it to anyone that this was
very precious you know how special this
was
and scott says we just couldn't tell you
warren that we already had a key because
we were part of the hacking group on
campus
so i'm curious about some of your
challenges that you faced are there some
things that you thought were going to be
super easy to do and then just turn out
to be nightmarishly difficult or
uh are there some things that you
thought would be really hard
um that
you know just seem to all the pieces
seem to fall into place
arthur ganson was invited to create a
sculpture for
the one of these windows here and he
created a version of what's called
margo's other cat and his most of his
sculptures if you know them are pretty
intimate small scale
this was
a experiment for him where
he it was exploded and he had all these
gears and this stuffed i mean it was a
you know stuffed cat it was a toy cat
and it was being flung around and you
know and the animal rights people in
this people's republic of cambridge
people's republic of cambridge came
forward and were outraged
outraged and so what we thought would be
a very effective
and street level attractor to the museum
had to be removed
it was censored
do you remember that jane i think didn't
i remember doing you know we did the
whole thing but i didn't remember that
oh my god that's amazing actually it's
hard for me to remember challenges
because mary dealt with so much that i'm
not sure i was actually aware of all the
things that were going
on
yeah my biggest challenge when i came is
that i came with a fixed idea as debbie
knows well
and some other comments who will know
too i was going to move this museum into
the metropolitan warehouse
and it was going to take five years
because if you look at the first
strategic plan that we oversaw
in my time that was the lead message you
know by the end of this plan will be in
the metro warehouse if that had been
done we'd have been in the metro
warehouse in 2010
and it probably is obvious to you all
that we didn't do that and the reason
was that was much harder to pull off
than i realized it was impossible in
fact
i do remember seeing that strategic plan
and thinking hmm
he never told me and no i didn't because
i don't do that
i just think good luck um but yes i
remember because harvey was yeah yeah
worked so hard to try and make that
happen and we actually pulled back from
doing it i'm quite struck but you asked
two questions if i remember one was a
challenge something you thought would be
easy and was hard that was the one
and the other thing what you thought
would be hard turned out to be easy was
actually in a sense getting permission
to go
and start the new museum in kendall
because
we had given up in my time the idea of
going into a new place and then suddenly
this opportunity sprang up
and i won't try and go into the details
but suddenly there was an opportunity
you never thought was there so that
would be the side of the coin
look at one that
i thought was going to be difficult and
then turned easy which was
around the hacks and the collection of
hacks and and i arrived
and i remember i got a call from someone
actually i don't remember the person's
name but i think he was in material
science anyway the student newspaper
which of course i've now forgotten the
name of the mi
the tech
had done an article about me arriving
and at some point i had obviously said
something that led them to believe that
i was going to take the police car off
display you know that so the article the
tenor of the article was who the hell
does this woman think she is
she doesn't understand mit
you know
how could she even conceive of it which
of course i had no such conception
anyway so i i he left a message i called
him back and we had a great conversation
and i wish i could remember who it was
because then we became friends but
um i remember thinking actually inside
oh my god how am i going to learn about
this hat collection and how are we going
to look after it or whatever and then
meeting well of course don was around
sorry to keep mentioning him but around
who sort of was calming me down about
how yes we would be able to conserve
them because of course i'm looking at
these things thinking how how are we
going to conserve that how are they
still going to be around in 100 years
except for the donuts which i don't
think ever need
needed conserving because they just was
still exactly the same 12 years after or
whatever anyway the doughnuts never
needed to be replaced
um they were dunkin donuts they were
dunkin donuts i was like by them you
never eat dunkin do you know like 12
years later they still look exactly the
same what is it that they have but then
meeting terry and just suddenly becoming
aware that there was this whole
community around the hacks that were
going to help me
get to grips and suddenly i thought like
i totally get this
you know there are so many people around
to help so that that was something that
caused me a little inner sort of angst
and then
soon became clear that everyone at mit
loved the hacks and so they were going
to
really be helpful about doing it so that
that was something that speaking of
humor is fun warren you started
something uh the ignoble awards
um and uh they uh
attracted quite a bit of attention and
my favorite is the year that they were
sponsored by you and kathy and others
invented kelvin the unisex fragrance
that made all wearers absolutely cool
and there were shirts and t-shirts and
about kelvin and
the fragrance but tell maybe people
about the ignoble awards many of you
have heard about them at harvard but
didn't know that they actually
originated here at the museum
we were approached by a student to
if we'd be interested in sponsoring it
and it sounded like a great idea so
we've
we uh reserved
uh
krisky
and uh
we did i think four or five years of it
before
it moved up the street to that other
school here in cambridge
but
at any rate
it was a very unusual
event
to say the least
i will say in theory kelvin was sold in
the shop and we haven't talked about the
shop but i know that the shop has been
really important to all four of your
um
uh tenure here at at the museum and i
wondered if you have some
memories of getting it how did that get
started and
you know the famous catalog and then
jane you had to we had a shop then we
didn't have a shop then we had a shop
that like how did this
uh
come to be i do vaguely remember
there had been a previous large store
that i never saw which hadn't done so
well i recall that it's just passed
discreetly over
when i started we had a tiny store and
it was a shelf or maybe two shelves
linked to what was then the main
entrance to this museum on the second
floor and it was it was sort of under
where the admissions staff person stood
and there might have been 20
different items for sale and the amazing
thing was i still remember that that
tiny store
not even really a store just to shut a
couple of shelves apparently it was
turning over i think the figure in my
head is 60 000 a year
so i mean that's not much for a store
but on the other hand
there's not much by way of a store so
it's like well there could be something
here you know and so that's why when we
opened this floor which was in 2007
we decided to take a gamble and bring
the store down to the ground floor
where it absolutely thrived well it had
a street presence which you'd never had
before so you know one of the
interesting things about the catalog
though is that occurs at precisely the
moment that the world is going digital
and i'm looking at david
nunez here and thinking a little bit
maybe to ask you a little bit about our
digital museum i i realized who started
who had the first website and
you know when did we
mary you were part of getting the very
first experiments with getting
collections online and jane
you've got a digitizing holography
swallow richard's
database right
yes
but actually we did
kara schneiderman who was our registrar
and collections manager who's now the
director of collections at jane's museum
started the museum website in the
mid-1990s when almost nobody had a
website and she did a fabulous job with
it and then um
really focused on the edgerton
collection which we had funding to
digitize and make available online so
that's kind of i would say the nucleus
or the starter collection for our um
digital collections
i'm um
interested
in uh
a question about people and audience
here for the museum and each of you
you've spoken about alumni and
we've talked about
people in public but who do you think of
when you first came here what was the
target audience and
how then have you viewed it as you know
what have been the opportunities to
expand that audience over time i think
there's a duality of the mit community
is a very important audience but then we
as a museum um we
want to serve the greater community too
so i think this that
figuring out that mission
and how to serve the mit community and
then at the same time the general public
i'll just say that as a starter
yeah yeah no i think that's right um
it felt like
it was
it was sort of everybody which is the
same as saying nobody
uh but
yeah i definitely when i came in felt
there was that um mit community without
question
the cambridge community and then
sort of people who were coming to find
out about mit you know i mean mit has
this sort of
incredible reputation across the world
and so there would be this sense in
which you you the museum was the place
to sort of present mit in all its
you know
all the facets um
and so
yeah i would i would say that's how i
sort of divided it in my head really
um and i don't know if that's changed a
lot i don't know well i think it is true
just reflecting on my time that when i
came
i think i wanted us to give a real
emphasis to audiences outside mit
and the way i used to put it so i must
have believed this because i can
remember this little spiel
and the spiel was you know mit folks
we really want you on the stage
uh more than we want you in the audience
and to me that's always been the case
you know that the mit
faculty and students are the single most
appealing exhibits
that the mit museum will ever have you
know and my colleagues have heard me say
this before if we if we have an mit
research student playing with some thing
on the
on the exhibition floor it will be the
star attraction whatever they're doing
when we open this ground floor
gary will remember we had a an
experimental wheel assembly
that had been made as part of the city
car project by folks in the media lab
and of course it was a it was an
experimental car so guess what
the working wheel assembly worked for
about 12 hours
and then it stopped
and of course it was a research student
project so after a time and whenever
they felt like it
some students turned up they didn't sort
of
think about whether there was any
audience they just came
a bunch of people in uh jeans and
t-shirts and laptops and they started
over there fiddling with this thing to
try and make it work and before long the
entire because this was the museum was
open the entire audience on the ground
floor had deserted all the other
exhibits and they were all crowded
around these research students
who were just simply playing
with a laptop and doing something who
knows it's always been that way in my
experience so i've always felt that our
greatest asset is the mit community but
we want to get them in front of
audiences who don't get a chance to meet
them every day so that was what i was
trying to do to swivel our attention as
far as visitors is concerned are
concerned but to do it with the whole of
mit behind us
i'm thinking as we come to the end of
this panel that i
was remembering my first day of work and
jane you called me into your office and
uh to discuss your plans for me and they
included a pair of exhibitions one of
them was the aforementioned robotics and
ai exhibit another was uh
an exhibit um
and and you said to me at the time i
always remember this robots are the
science museums what dinosaurs are the
natural history museums we must do an
exhibit and we come by it
honestly here
uh but
but then you said nobody really knows
what the mit museum has to offer
in terms of exhibitions and programs but
to the extent they expect anything or
have any conception it's that this will
be a place that they can learn something
about mit
its history its achievements its
challenges
and why mit matters and i thought that
might be a great question to pose to you
a little bit about
why you think mit still needs a museum
and
we're about to we're at a real
inflection point in our history we're
going to move into
extraordinarily
a new facility
we have an amazing new team of people
here on board to make that transition
and
i'm really wondering if you might share
with us some of your
uh thoughts about the museum what makes
it distinctive why it's valuable what
and what you hope maybe for the future
i'm i'm really interested to hear
what you think john i i mean to me it
seems so exciting
to be a real gateway i mean i think
we've always seen the museum as a
gateway into mit but now it's sort of
physically literal as well as sort of
you know in terms of um
what we're doing so
i don't know i i'm tempted to say
honestly that if mit didn't have the
museum it would have to reinvent it
and so i see it more not more but i see
it partly in terms of what the institute
actually needs
so mit is as we all know
it's a place devoted to
knowledge in pursuit of public service
and in pursuit of the public good if you
look at the mission statement for mit
that's what it's about
and i think we know enough to know that
however smart a group of people is they
can't do that successfully if they're
doing it in a closed room on their own
they're not going to be able to
get the changes they want and make the
world a better place
you need to engage the wider community
that i just think mit's work is so
important that it's very important that
that a wider community be engaged in
what the institute is doing and of
course we're not the only people at mit
who do that but i do think this is a
focus
in the institute for that kind of
engagement
and that's i think why it's so important
i just think it's where we are in the
21st century
we know there's a lot of
questioning of expertise there's a lot
of questioning of science in recent
years in ways that some of us might
never have imagined
and if we're going to address those
issues we've got to be out there
and what better place to be out there
from than
well i hope
you all might join me in thanking our
panelists for sharing some of their
memories and thoughts um we're going to
have an opportunity to share stories
with each other in a few moments our
caterers are going to bring in
treats for all of us but um thank you
warren mary john and
jane
this woman had the best application
letter i've hired many people
it started dear i don't know whoever
search committee
um as i sit in my house that is about
two and a half million she had the exact
number smoots from the mit museum that
was the first sentence and i was like
okay i think this is who we need you
know anyway
so yes i'm the woman that hired you my
name is jake
so i got out of order but anyway i wanna
thank you all both for today but also
for 50 years of amazing service to this
museum